YUFENG GUO: There is a
lot of structured data
out there, perhaps more
than any other type.
And it's ripe for use
with machine learning.
Let's explore a new tool
that aims to automatically
build and deploy
machine learning models
on structured data.
Will it live up to the promise?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to try out
AutoML tables, one of the
newest AutoML products
that Google has added.
AutoML tables enables you to
automatically build and deploy
state-of-the-art machine
learning models on structured
data faster than
you could by hand.
It automates modeling
on a wide range
of data types from
numbers and classes
to strings, timestamps,
lists, and nested fields.
What's interesting
about AutoML tables
is that you can do all of
this without any coding work.
You just take an exported CSV
file, click a few buttons,
wait a while, and you get
a very highly tuned model
on the other end.
The team has worked
hard to enable the tool
to work for a wide variety
of different data types.
And it really explores that
vast space of possible models
and hyperparameters to try to
optimize things on your behalf.
Let's see what using
AutoML tables looks like.
The first step is to import
your training data at the Import
tab, give it a name,
select the source--
either a table from BigQuery or
a file on Google Cloud Storage.
We're going to use
an open dataset that
describes marketing outcomes
of a Portuguese bank.
And we'll try to model whether
a bank deposit will happen.
This first step
takes a bit of time
as the system analyzes the
columns of your dataset.
Once it's complete,
you'll get to edit
the auto-generated
schema and select
the column for predicting on.
Here, you can also update
the column type, as well as
whether it is nullable or not.
The third tab is called Analyze.
This is a pretty
interesting view.
And I think it will be useful
for those with datasets
that have a lot
of columns to get
a nice overview of their data.
You can even click on the
different column names
to see some statistics
about your columns.
After analyzing the data,
we're ready to do the training.
This is where AutoML really
shines because, well, all you
have to do is click Train.
There are some options
that you can set,
including a maximum
budget of training hours.
This enables you to
experiment with your data
if you want and limit that
training time before committing
to a full, longer training run.
You'll notice that the training
times shown are somewhat
on the long side of things.
And that's because it's
not only doing model tuning
but also selecting what model
to use in the first place.
So as a result,
there's a lot of things
happening during training.
But luckily for us, we
don't have to do anything.
Time to just go get lunch
or something, I guess.
And we're back.
Now we're onto the fifth
tab of AutoML Tables, which
is Evaluation.
If you've used some of the
other AutoML products before,
this will look pretty familiar.
You can see how
the training did,
as well as metrics about
the model's performance.
And finally, in tab number
6, we can deploy the model
to get predictions.
There's even an editor in the
browser that will make requests
to your endpoint,
so you don't need
to set up a local environment
to make these calls to try
and test out your endpoint.
Notice also, there's an
option at the top of the page
to toggle between online
predictions via the REST API
and batch predictions, which
allow you to upload a CSV file
or point to a BigQuery table
and get prediction results
on that entire file or table.
Considering the amount
of time it takes to use,
AutoML Tables enables
you to achieve
a much higher level
of model performance
than you could reach manually.
So if you have some
structured data
you're thinking of doing
some machine learning on,
use this as an excuse
to try out AutoML Tables
to see if it's useful for you.
By selecting from
state-of-the-art models
and then carefully tuning
the models during training,
AutoML Tables can potentially
save you a lot of work.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it,
hit that Like button,
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out AutoML
tables and harness the insights
in your structured data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]